style grace and elegance aren't terms
usually associated with modern American
action movies the genre is full of
high-octane explosions brutality and
bloodshed but when it comes to the craft
of filmmaking they can often be
unmemorable John wick changed all that
the Keanu Reeves led revenge thriller is
epically violent but it's elegant
violence captured in a way we don't get
to see too often the characters sharp
suits and sharper shooting have left a
huge mark on the action movie landscape
including in a few ways you might not
yet have noticed here's how John wick
rewrote the rules for modern action low
on ammo to understand John wicks
influence on action movies you have to
look at the state of the genre in the
years before its release seven years
after the Bourne Ultimatum rounded off
its own influential trilogy the genre
felt tired full of same old structures
and stale premises there were occasional
gems like the old man action of the
first taken or the Indonesian import the
raid but for the most part mainstream
Hollywood action was plagued with
insubstantial CGI heavy spectacle
success stories were frequently genre
hybrids such as Lucy or edge of tomorrow
all-out action was reduced to the likes
of a good day to die hard or white house
down movies like these feel like
half-baked efforts full of ridiculous
spectacle that looks fake with no weight
audiences were lulled into complacency
when John wick came along and had the
guts to send a puppy to doggy heaven
people weren't ready for the impact
I know gun foo John Wick's biggest asset
is its energetic implementation of gun
foo a mixture of Kung Fu and gunplay the
cinematic fighting style was first
popularized by Hong Kong action director
John Woo whose movies help create a
sub-genre of heroic bloodshed these
stories feature characters who value
honor and integrity and follow strict
codes of ethics often the protagonists
will stop at nothing to exact revenge
with the resulting carnage made more
palatable by the sense of morality we
know they have John wick is part of this
tradition but what made it so different
why did we become so attached to a blank
slate nobody of a character we've never
met before
that can nobody is Chum like the dance
of doom directors chance to hell ski and
david leitch made their marks in
Hollywood as stuntmen most notably on
the matrix where Stachowski performed as
Keanu Reeves stunt double this boots on
the ground perspective gave the pair a
unique perspective when it came to
shooting action as directors they saw
the camera operators often regarded
action sequences as stressful exercises
and hiding imperfections so they
rehearsed and choreographed each scene
with camera people included leaving no
room for surprises when it came time to
shoot for authenticity the deal was
determined to use as much footage of
Reeves as possible the actor performed
the vast majority of the stunts himself
spending four months of pre-production
honing his techniques training included
Japanese jiu-jitsu Brazilian jiu-jitsu
standing judo and Firearms training
designed for close quarters combat the
result is fight choreography that flows
freely in a kind of brutal ballet
violence and John wick is so stylized
that it comes off as a hypnotic dance
performed by a professional hitman and
is unfortunate victims stylish shooters
John wick proved these stuntmen turned
directors understand much more than just
bike choreography the cinematography of
John wick is as stylish as the man
himself criminal underworld are supposed
to be murky gritty full of dirt yet
wicks world is saturated in otherworldly
hues his fights take place inside of
exclusive clubs ornate hotels and
mirrored museums the fights themselves
are stylish too John wick rejected the
sharply edited frantic action that has
come to be a crutch in the genre
instead wide shots and long tapes
capture every punch kick and pistol whip
you're left wanting to rewatch the movie
just to admire the ways that set pieces
are staged an underworld worth visiting
John wicks world building is unmatched
in the action genre the story takes
place within an intricate Network
centering around the Continental a hotel
in New York City which serves as a safe
haven for assassins the universe is as
detailed as it is original Winston the
hotel's owner is a charming and affable
enigma with
power outside of the hotel special gold
coins are exchanged for criminals only
services from seemingly legitimate
businesses tailors offer bulletproof
suits and Somali aids are experts in
pistols instead of Pino it's an
underworld you can feel intimately even
if it's never all that explained fight
like wick years on from John wicks
release the ripples on the movie
industry can be felt everywhere you look
put simply vengeance and well done
violence are very in one air of the
style is leeches own atomic blonde a
spiritual sibling to win Charlize Theron
has even said she was inspired to dip
into the Cold War era action flick
because of her admiration for John wick
leach then went on to up the action
stakes as director for Deadpool to
another John wick producer vassal eunuch
has said the combat in the 2018 Robin
Hood was inspired by wick saying to
Collider the stuff we're doing with the
bow and arrow it's the same thing that
Keanu does with the gun the producers of
the remake of cult classic Highlander
clearly have the same idea hirings to
hell ski to apply wick style to that
movie's swordplay as director in short
John wick has inspired action film
makers to up their game with highly
skilled assassin flick starring men and
women both there's Jennifer Lawrence's
red Sparrow taraji P Henson's proud Mary
and Jennifer Garner's peppermint a
revenge thriller that's been described
as John wick with a female protagonist
pretty much wing it from there checking
in John wicks Blair for world-building
has also spread across the action genre
the hit man's bodyguard includes an
assassin underworld similar to wick and
the Jodie Foster starring Hotel Artemus
has a premise that's heavily reminiscent
of the Continental that movie stars
foster as the manager of a hotel which
doubles as a safe space for criminals to
seek medical treatment and lay low in
other words the telltale marks of John
wick are now everywhere and there are no
signs of the phenomenon slowing down
wicks stylish action has smashed the
proverbial sledgehammer into
conventional genre fare unearthing a
winning formula the boogeyman has
changed the action
and he's only getting started thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]